[Music]  I'm very very particular with my  melodies and stuff and I work with all  these people from different genres same  DJ Avicii has died at the age of 28 his  rep tells et it is with profound sorrow  that we announced the loss of Tim  Bergling also known as Avicii the family  is devastated and we ask everyone to  please respect their need for privacy in  this difficult time no further  statements will be given the Swedish DJ  was found in Muscat Oman on Friday  afternoon details of his death are  unknown in August VG released an EP and  was gearing up to release a third studio  album he also premiered a documentary  chronicling a 2016 decision to retire  from touring VG suffered from ongoing  health problems including acute  pancreatitis on Tuesday he was nominated  for a Billboard Music Award for top  dance/electronic album  [Music]  you  [Music]